[Music]  the weekend drops a brand-new trippy and  goosebumps inspired music video for  party monster and shares his thoughts on  marriage the 26 year old graces the  cover of GQ magazine along with chance  the rapper inside sharing his thoughts  on marriage quote I feel like I'm the  kind of guy that would have kids before  getting married the first thing would be  kids marriage is scary to me man  the interview happened around one month  after his split from Bella Hadid he's  the best we're still great friends on  Wednesday photos surfaced of the weekend  kissing Selena Gomez outside of a  restaurant in Los Angeles can't keep my  hands to myself shortly afterward Bella  unfollowed Selena on Instagram